اذا مقتل المستشار في الحرس الثوري
الايراني كان حاضرا ايضا في اسرائيل حيث
قالت وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه ان الجيش
يستعد لرد ايراني متوقع من لبنان او سوريا
وقد يضيف ذلك الكثير على المشهد المحتدم
في الجبهه الشماليه من لبنان نستطلع هذا
المشهد مع مراسلينا في الجليل الاعلى
مراسله الجزيره فاطمه خمايسه ومن بلده
رميش جنوبيه لبنان مدير مكتب الجزيره مازن
ابراهيم هل هناك
تحسب من اتساع الصراع وان يكون هناك رد
ايراني مثلا من جهات مرتبطه بايران
مازن في الواقع جمال بطبيعه الحال اغتيال
الجنرال رضي موسوي
في دمشق يلقي بظلاله على طول هذه الجبهه
الجنوبيه للبنان الجميع يتوقع الجميع
يحتسب ويفكر ماذا سيكون رد حزب الله ولكن
دعني احيلك هنا الى تجارب سابقه بان حزب
الله لم يقم سابقا بالرد على اي اغتيال
لمسؤولين في الحرس الثوري الايراني ولكن
الحرس هو من كان يتكفل بذلك الامر
وبالتالي صحيح وفق المصادر التي تواصلت
معها بان التوتر سيتزايد عند هذه الجبهه
الجنوبيه للبنان ولكن حزب الله لا يعمل
وفق مبدا رده الفعل بمعنى ان تعامله مع
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على طول الخط خط
الجبهه الجنوبيه للبنان ينم عن استراتيجيه
وتكتيك واضح بدا يتزايد منذ لحظه انطلاق
هذه المواجهات في الثامن من اكتوبر هنا
وبالتالي استهداف الجنرال الايراني اليوم
والمستشار في الحرس الثوري الايراني لن
يؤدي بشكل طلق قائي الى تنفيذ حزب الله
هجمات ربطا بهذا الاستهداف ولكن سيكون
هنالك استكمال للتكتيك الذي بات يعتمده
حزب الله منذ نحو اسبوعين في كيفيه
مقاربته لكل هذا الملف الساخن هنا عند
الجبهه الجنوبيه للبنان والذي بدا يتجلى
من خلال تكتيك يقوم على ضرب البن البنى
التحتيه لكامل المستوطنات الاسرائيليه على
طول الخط الحدودي نحن نتحدث عن 43 مستوطنه
الاسرائيليه باتت منذ اسبوعين تحت النيران
المباشره لصواريخ حزب الله وبالتالي هذا
هو التكتيك الذي رصدناه مؤخرا وهذا ما
يعلنه حزب الله من خلال بياناته المتعدده
وايضا من خلال الاسلحه التي باتت تستخدم
لاستهداف هذه المستوطنات هذا ما حصل اليوم
على سبيل المثال ست مستوطنات يجري
استهدافها وايضا بالامس هنالك استهداف
لمستوطنات والبيانات الصادره عن حزب الله
بالاضافه الى العمليات التي ينفذها هي هي
تشير الى انه بات يستهدف المباني والمراكز
العمرانيه في داخل هذه المستوطنات ردا على
الاستهداف الاسرائيلي للمدنيين اللبنانيين
وايضا دعنا نشير هنا ايضا جمال بان كتائب
عز الدين قسم في لبنان اليوم عندما اطلقت
صواريخها وتبنت هذا الاطلاق من جنوب لبنان
قالت بانها استهدفت مستوطنه ليمان وقاعده
عسكريه هناك وبالتالي ايضا ليمان هي تندرج
ضمن هذه المستوطنات التي قامت اسرائيل
باخلاقها خلال اليومين الماضيين وبالتالي
هذا هو التكتيك المعتمد الان من قبل الحزب
اخلاء كل المنطقه المقابله للحدود
اللبنانيه في عمق سبعه كيلومترات وهذا
الامر ادى الى خروج عشرات الاف المستوطنين
الاسرائيليين والذين يقدر عددهم ب 120,000
ويقول حزب الله بانه سيعمل على تحويل تلك
المنطقه الى منطقه عسكريه توجه اليها
صواريخ المقاومه طالما كانت اسرائيل وقوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تستهدف المدنيين في
لبنان وايضا ربطا بالتطورات في غزه على
قاعده بان كل تسارع وكل استمرار للعدوان
الاسرائيلي في قطاع غزه سيؤدي الى تفعيل
هذه الجبهه التي وصفها حزب الله بانها
جبهه مسانده له في هذه المنطقه مازن
ابراهيم ابقى معنا تحول فاطمه خمايسه
فاطمه هذا عمليه الاغتيال
هذه هل كانت لها تداعيات خاصه على المشهد
المحتدم في الواقع على الجبهه الشماليه مع
لبنان هل هناك من مظاهر يعني غير
طبيعيه بلا شك جمال يعني العمليه الاغتيال
التي حصلت في سوريا والتي طالت احد القاده
البارزين في الحرس الثوري الايراني تنعكس
هنا بشكل كبير على الجبهه الشماليه تقرر
اغلاق البلدات الحدوديه الاسرائيليه بيوم
اضافي نتحدث عن منع دخول او خروج اي شخص
الى هذه البلدات الحدوديه الاسرائيليه
القريبه من لبنان وبالتالي هنالك رفع حاله
التاهب الامنيه في المنطقه الحدوديه مع
لبنان وايضا هنالك تعليمات جديده للجبهه
الداخليه التابعه للجيش الاسرائيلي والتي
تقول وتنص على رفع حاله التاهب الامني في
ايضا في مناطق جنوب الجولان تحسبا لاي
عمليات ستصدر من الجانب السوري باتجاه هذه
المنطقه لذلك نرى ان الرقعه التوتر باتت
تتسع بشكل اكبر لا سما وان هذه العمليه
تاتي في ظل وجود وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
يف جلان في الجبهه الشماليه وبالتزامن مع
وجوده تم تنفيذ عمليه اغتيال لاحد القاده
البارزين في الحرس الثوري الايراني نتحدث
عن راضي موسوي وهو احد المسؤولين عن محور
المقاومه في سوريا وبالتالي هذا الامر
تزامن مع وجود وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي يوف
جلنت وهنالك من يربط بشكل مباشر رغم عدم
تبني اسرائيل لهذه العمليه في سوريا ولكن
هنالك من يقول ان اسرائيل مسؤوله بشكل
كبير عن هذه العمليه و تقف من ورائها لكن
تصريحات وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي يف جلان
كانت مباشره لحزب الله ومفادها ان حزب
الله يتابع ما يحصل في غزه وما يحصل من
دمار يمكن ان يحصل في بيروت في حاله في
حال استمر الحزب من تصعيد عمليات العسكريه
ضد اسرائيل وبالتالي هنالك حاله ترقب تسود
المنطقه في حال وجود اي عمليات رد فعل
سواء من قبل الجانب السوري وايضا من قبل
الجانب اللبناني التعليمات ايضا لا زالت
على حالها اغلاق كافه نعم الطرق الرئيسيه
المؤديه الى البلدات الحدوديه وهذا ياتي
في ظل اشتداد القصف الصاروخي الذي تم رصده
خلال اليوم نتحدث عن استهداف لبلدات
اسرائيليه عده من ضمنها بلده حدوديه تبعد
عن الحدود اللبنانيه 6ه كيلومترات الا وهي
بيت هلال وايضا كان هنالك اعتراضات
صاروخيه وايضا سقوط للصواريخ في مناطق
مفتوحه في الجليل الغربي وبالتالي الرقعه
باتت تتسع والترقب هو سيد الموقف خاصه في
الساعات القادمه وهذه الضربه يراها بعض
المحللون الاسرائيليون بانها هي رساله
تحذيريه الى حزب الله بان اسرائيل تقدر ان
تقصف في سوريا وان تواصل ايضا حركه
الطيران بشكل مريح في الاجواء اللبنانيه
هذا وفق ما صرح به وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
وبالتالي جميع هذه العوامل هي بمثابه
رسائل رادعه لحزب الله ومفاد ان على
الحزب مراسله الجزيره متحدث عبد الجليل
الاعلى شكرا كذلك لمدير مكتب الجزيره مازن
ابراهيم كان معنا من بلده رميش في جنوب
لبنان